VAN RIPER: Hi, I'm Van Riper,
and I work with our Google
Developer Groups all
around the world.
Today we're starting our first
ever Google Developers Tech
Roundup, a monthly show bringing
to you the latest and
greatest in what's happening
for Google Developers.
I'd also like to introduce my
co-host, Stephanie Liu.
STEPHANIE LIU: Hi, everybody.
My name is Stephanie Liu.
I lead the Global Programs team
for developer relations.
I work very closely with Van.
VAN RIPER: And we also have
Adriana Cerundolo.
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO: Hi, I'm
Adriana, and I am the
Community Manager for the Google
Developer Groups, and I
have the pleasure of working
with Steph and Van also here
in Mountainview.
VAN RIPER: So today, we're going
to talk a little bit
about I/O, since that was
recently some of our favorite
moments and some of
the top news.
We'd also love to hear from
you what you found
interesting as well.
But I'll start with my favorite
moment from the keynote.
It was actually before the
keynote even started.
Because of my work with the
community, that really kind of
gave me chills when I saw 250
plus organizers all stand up
before the keynote even began,
waving their local banners and
chanting GDG, GDG.
I love the passion of our
developer community, and it
was great to see that in
action at the keynote.
How about you, Stephanie?
STEPHANIE LIU: I think my
favorite moment from the
keynote was a mid section.
He was talking about his
sci-fi-- you know, how we're
living in the future,
his whole "Star
Trek," sci-fi thing.
So I thought the Google
Now demo was awesome.
Being able to see the thinking,
the principles
behind how we're moving forward
in that space with
answer, converse, anticipate,
with anticipate being the
really futuristic, we're giving
information before you
even know you want it.
I thought that was awesome.
And as a bonus, when Amit got
up on stage, he said he grew
up in India.
And all of our Indian GDGs, you
could hear them, they were
near the front row,
just went crazy.
So I thought that was special.
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO: Yeah, I'll
have to say for me my favorite
part was the Maps update.
Because I've always
loved maps.
Ever since I was a kid, I would
have them all over my
walls and just loved
geography.
So I thought it was great
to see that now we have
customizable maps.
And it's also that integration
was [INAUDIBLE].
And you can see reviews and
so on all in your map.
And they actually went and did,
and they panned out to
using Google Earth and
up into the universe
view during the keynote.
And that was the backdrop for
the rest of the segment, and
that was really awesome.
Loved that.
VAN RIPER: Yeah, but actually
turning now to more about the
substance of the keynote, the
things that I personally--
and for developers
in particular--
for myself, as a long time Java
developer, I was really
excited by the announcement
of Android Studio.
I can remember when I was a
young developer using early
access releases [INAUDIBLE]
first IntelliJ IDEA for
Java developers.
And now it's kind of a new world
with Android development
having the early access preview
releases of Android
Studio, which is based on the
very solid community edition
of IntelliJ IDEA.
So now there's a free
environment that's based on
this environment that is
a pleasure to use.
And even though it's in early
access, I found Android Studio
already to be a pleasure
to use.
So I encourage you Java
developers to check that out.
What about you, Stephanie?
STEPHANIE LIU: Well, I thought
that some of the kind of news
that may have been lost in the
shuffle was some of the
sessions that we did on Google's
two languages, which
are Go and Dart.
And there was a theme, which
was performance.
So for Dart, if I had to
choose a session, I'd
recommend Web Languages
and VMs, Fast
Code Always in Fashion.
It's Always in Fashion with
Lars Bak and Kasper Lund.
So there's a cool demo in there,
so look for that, where
they're zombies.
So you have that.
Just like the performance
enhancements using that single
instruction multiple data,
which Dart supports.
And for Go, Go 1.1, there was
also a bunch of optimization
that came out with the .1
release with garbage collector
stuff, [? mathematician ?]
and some tweaks to
standard library.
It's compatible with 1.0, and
you'll note, if you upgrade,
you'll probably notice your code
running a little faster.
And if I had to recommend a
talk to watch for that, it
would be Rob Pike's talk about
advanced Go [INAUDIBLE]
currency patterns.
So if you've been hesitant
because the languages are
still pretty nascent, I'd
recommend you check them out
because it's fast moving.
It's getting more mature.
The teams for Dart and Go are
actually both very responsive.
And it would be like a cool
time to get into it.
My own personal story about Go
is, well, my fiance and I got
engaged like seven months
ago or six months ago.
The first concession, the
first wedding planning
concession I made, was to do
our wedding website on App
Engine Go instead of
App Engine Python.
Because he really loves
Go, and he thinks
it's a great language.
And so I could see it because
I'm being a good future wife,
compromises.
But also I thought it would
be a great to do Go.
And even though I haven't made
any significant patches yet, I
still got three months.
So I'm like [INAUDIBLE]
digging into it.
VAN RIPER: And don't forget the
PHP announcement as well.
It may not be a new sexy
language like Dart or Go, but
I think there's a lot of
developers out there that--
STEPHANIE LIU: Stately?
VAN RIPER: There's a lot of
developers out there using PHP
that were probably very
happy to see that
announcement as well.
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO:
It's awesome.
I just want to say I hope that's
the only concession you
have to make, at least
before your wedding
starts with the planning.
STEPHANIE LIU: Oh, yeah.
[INAUDIBLE] hot pink.
Hot pink and purple
as my colors.
I'm just kidding.
It's not.
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO: I love it.
I love it.
It's going to be great.
You're going to look great
in that color.
I can just see it.
Well, I just want to say my
personal favorite update was
with Apps Script.
I think this is an
important update.
So we already know that you can
use Apps Scripts to extend
into Google Spreadsheets, and
now you can extend into Docs,
which I think is really
important because now you can
use custom menus, dialogs,
and triggers.
This is something that
personally is going to make my
life much easier, especially
the update with
Apps Scripts and forms.
So it's going to make those
interactions with form
submissions that much richer.
And also there's going to be
much more that you can do with
the form submissions to get
information from when they
submit and so on.
So it's just going to make all
the work that we do with forms
and the events just much more
efficient and easier.
So I'm excited about that.
VAN RIPER: So that was just
a few of our favorite
announcements and technical
components from I/O. I know
there's a lot more--
there's way more that was
covered there on Google+ and
Chrome, and you need to really
check out all the videos from
I/O. And we'd love to hear from
you what your favorite
pieces of what you thought the
most significant developer
announcements were.
Let us know in the comments.
For our next segment, we have
Kim Cameron from the BigQuery
team joining us.
Kim and Amy Unruh gave a great
talk about the sensors used to
collect data at Google I/O this
year and how the Google
Cloud Platform was used to do
cool stuff with the data.
So take it away, Kim.
KIM CAMERON: Hey, everyone.
So you may have heard about the
project called the Data
Sensing Lab at Google I/O. And
I'm here to talk to you a
little bit about that.
So first of all, before we get
into what it actually was, how
did it get started?
So our colleague Michael
Manoochehri on the BigQuery
team went to Strata in February,
and he was really
impressed by a project that the
O'Reilly Data Sensing Lab
team had set up.
It basically took about 50
sensors, put them all over the
conference, collected
environmental data, and then
did cool stuff with it,
visualized it for people.
It was a pretty big success.
And Michael thought, why can't
we do that even bigger.
So he decided to do this at
Google I/O. Instead of 50
sensors, we did 500 sensors.
And like at Strata,
we set them up all
over the Moscone Center.
And we wanted to figure out cool
stuff about the data, and
we wanted to show it to you in
really interesting ways.
So I really encourage all of you
to go to the YouTube talk
that will be shown at
the end to get full
details about the project.
There was a lot involved.
I'm going to summarize it
a bit for you right now.
And there were two main
components, the hardware end
and the software end.
So first off, for the hardware,
we took 500 sensors,
as I've mentioned.
And these were made up
of two main pieces.
First of all, there's an
Arduino board that
makes up the base.
Arduinos you've probably
heard of.
They're open source
electronic boards.
They're really cheap.
You can get them for
$20 at any Radio
Shack or other store.
To that, we added a custom
sensor shield.
And the O'Reilly Data Sensing
Lab team ended
up doing this work.
We partner with them
on this project.
Each sensor shield has some
built-in sensors,
environmental sensors, for
temperature, pressure,
humidity, and also light.
And then they have the
capability to include three
additional sensors, specifically
air quality,
pressure, which is-- we had
these mats around Moscone that
if people stepped on them,
they registered--
and also RF noise, which
we had tuned to GSM.
And we had about 100 each that
had one of each of the
optional components, and then
all 500 had the base ones,
which were, like I mentioned,
temperature and pressure and
humidity and light.
So we set those up
all over Moscone.
And the next issue was, how
would they communicate with
each other.
So we partnered with Digi
International, who also were
involved at Strata.
And they hooked up
a mesh network.
And this allowed the sensors to
communicate with each other
over a much greater distance
than if we had set up, say, a
Wi-Fi network.
So then the software piece
comes into play.
And that's where our team built
the app and figured out
how we were going to work
with this data.
And we used many parts of the
Cloud platform, specifically
App Engine, BigQuery,
Compute Engine.
We used App Engine Data Store.
Lots of pieces involved.
We wanted to be able to build
an infrastructure without
doing a lot of the core work
to put the pieces together.
We wanted to be able to take
in the data, analyze it and
visualize it very simply.
So just to give you a brief
rundown of how we did that.
First of all, we have all these
streams of data coming
at us from this mesh network.
And we need to be able to put
that somewhere quickly so we
can keep getting the data.
So that, we used App Engine.
And we specifically used App
Engine task queues to go off,
grab the data asynchronously,
and put it into the App Engine
Data Store, where we could use
Data Store's system to be able
to query things like the most
recent 100 readings for heat
from all of the sensors,
things like that.
We also used the task queues to
get the data into BigQuery.
And we wanted to do that to be
able to enable more robust
queries for things like
aggregates, so the sum
function, for example.
So we had the data in both
of these data sources.
We also used Compute Engine to
do some analysis on the data.
And moving forward, we're hoping
to be able to do even
more types of analysis.
And we also used some
visualization scripts to be
able to output things that were
going on in the kiosks
that were around Moscone.
Specifically, I think we had one
that was showing where the
most recent pressure was
around the conference.
You could see in front of the
doors there was a lot of
traffic, at the base
of the escalators.
We even put some sensors in some
interesting places, like
there was a blimp that
was floating around.
We had a few of the
sensors up there.
As well as in, there was a car
that you could sit in.
We had a pressure mat in there
so you could see how often
people were getting in
and out of the car.
And so we did this to really
help see more about what was
going on at Moscone than you
might normally be able to see.
And we think that this opens the
door for doing really cool
analysis on things like, if
people walk around in a
certain area, does the air
quality go up or down?
And actually, we had one
visualization for that, with
the help of Tableau, who ended
up hooking up some
visualizations through their
connector to BigQuery.
And we did see a correlation
between number of steps that
people were taking in an area,
and the air quality did
actually go down, which
was kind of funny.
So this project really helped
us do cool things like that.
And we think in the future
we can do even more.
And to wrap it up, we do
plan on continuing to
work on this project.
We're hoping to do further
installations at other
conferences or events.
And we are also planning on open
sourcing the project in
the future, as well as the
dataset is available, the
entire BigQuery dataset.
You can go look at
it yourself.
And all this information is
listed at datasensinglab.com,
where we're going to have all
of that stuff in the future.
VAN RIPER: So Kim, we have some
of the sensor hardware
used at Google I/O here
in the studio.
I have one in my hand
right here.
How would developers
get this hardware
for their own projects?
KIM CAMERON: So that's a good
question, and actually, at the
conference, that was one of the
main things people were
asking at the booth.
How do I get this
sensor shield?
Because obviously you can roll
your own, but they wanted the
ability to have it now.
And you can actually pre-order
those at the
datasensinglab.com site.
The O'Reilly Data Sensing Lab
team is planning on making
those available in the future.
So you can certainly
access those now.
VAN RIPER: Great.
Well thanks, Kim for
that brief overview
of your full talk.
I hope people go and see the
full talk by Kim and Amy after
seeing this introduction.
And there will be links to that
video as well as links
where you can give us feedback
in the notes to this show.
Well, that was awesome.
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO: Man, I really
think we better wrap
this up before the air quality
continues to decrease.
VAN RIPER: Sounds good.
Well, I hope you enjoyed this
first edition of the Google
Developers Tech Roundup.
We hope to see you a month from
now for our second show.
In the meantime, if you have
something you'd like us to
share around Google Tech,
use the hashtag #gdtech.
We're going to close with a
little montage of our photos
of Google Developers in action
from I/O. And again, use the
#gdtech hashtag to share photos
with us that you'd like
to see on the next month.
So until next time, take care.
[MUSIC PLAYING]